[Musique]
bonjour et bien que c'est ce taux vous
voilà de retour après une première
expérience de candidature à l'élection
municipale à saint pierre en 2014
pourquoi revenir dans l'arène ai-je
envie de dire aux libyens de sesto en
2020 on venu en 2020 tout à fait normal
en 2014
ma liste appelait génération st-pie ans
nous changer ça donc nous étions partis
pour un changement le changement a été
opéré
sauf que l'exploit de son lève juste
l'espoir ça a été juste un mirage
quelques mois après nous avons vite
compris qu'il n'y a aucun changement
il y a une certaine continuité dans
cette commune de plus nous assistons à
une une gouvernance je dirais très
marquée par la présence de monsieur rafa
je ne dis pas le maire je dis monsieur
rafah cette présence même sans grand
chose aller dans le conseil municipal
parce que moi je ne suis pas à la mairie
je ne suis pas dans une je suis pas de
juin je ne suis pas conseiller et je ne
suis pas dans des commissions je ne suis
que citoyenne de sépia et que je vais
régulièrement aux conseils municipaux
ja j'ai observé simplement un homme seul
puisque tous ses conseillers tout le
monde personne ne parle un conseil
municipal où j'attendais un débat aucun
débat simplement un homme
ils vous donnent certaines directives ya
certaines choses les projets et vous les
présente
ils sont très peu discuté ils sont juste
votée j'en veux pour preuve que certains
projets sont propres aux polémiques
s'allume du musée par exemple celle du
musée où je n'ai pas compris j'ai juste
compris que au mois d'avril la fondation
clément a fait une proposition de
pouvoir pour accéder en appel d'offres
l'appel d'offres a été
au moins au 1er août une association qui
s'appelle culture à rome et à missionner
comme on n'a pas beaucoup de temps on
pourra pas refaire tout où le job c'est
de s'amuser mais si vous pouvez résumé
parce qu'on va pardonner je vous laisse
je voulais juste dire c'est pot fait
encore juste vous dire que comment se
fait-il qu'une association qui
n'existaient pas et pu aller en appel
d'offres et est validé et que les
travaux ont commencé le dirigeant alors
je ne pense qu'à poser la question mais
le maire dit que cette délibération du
conseil municipal de et a été donné à la
fondation clément du groupe bernard
alioth et non pas à la société
effectivement qu'il n'avait pas été
créée c'est une sous société une sous
structure qui a été créé par la
fondation pour gérer le musée voici ce
que répond le maire mais on aura le
temps d'y revenir sur thur bébé dites
moi justement comme vous parlez du maire
sortant christian enfin la question du
soutien de l'investiture du ppm se pose
pour ce scrutin 2020 puisque semble-t-il
christian rafa qui a côtoyé le ppm au
sein d'un ensemble pour une martinique
nouvelle a demandé le soutien donc de ce
parti quel est votre positionnement
compte tenu de cette situation julian
sesto on le rappelle vous êtes membre du
ppm un tacle de candidate je dirais
c'est une attaque personnelle
s'il faut se positionner autrement si le
ppm qui va selon le comité va se
positionner et prendre une discussion à
ce moment et j'attendrai sereinement
vous demandez-vous le l'investiture ou
le soutien du ppm
j'ai une liste qui n'est pas ppm
moi je suis ppm mais ma liste n est pas
ppm donc je demanderai s'il le faut
c'est en taillant l'heure s'il a fauché
deux malgré le soutien avez vous du
nouveau eliane c'est tout pour ce
scrutin municipal et communautaire à
saint pierre alors le nom du groupe n'a
pas changé génération c'est bien voilà
donc c'est le même nom pour le groupe
pour la liste oui mais est-ce que vous
avez quand même changer la composition
de la liste est ce que voilà ce qui est
un peu de yannick nouveau parce que ma
liste j'ai eu des décès j'ai eu des
départs donc il y aura quelques
changements mais pratiquement ça sera
parce que la même liste
ce cas de vol alors pour terminer quelle
décision municipale vous paraît
nécessaire est fondamentale en urgence
pour la population pierotti en urgence
il faudrait avant dialogue parce que en
s'entendant plus maintenant et il ya une
certaine division qui est vraiment très
néfaste sur saint pierre
surtout dans les quartiers le quartier
no quand le maire qualifie de zeno fob
une partie de la population parce qu'ils
ont voté pour une est qu'une candidate
de l'extrême droite au lieu de chercher
la cause il les qualifie simplement le
canton vous vous nous donnez vous
recevez et les jeunes à la pour le sport
et où on est carrément à l'abandon le
maire les seniors je pense que souvent
il les fait venir ce sont juste des
vitrines mais je ne pense pas que le
problème le problème de fond n'est
jamais réglé ses jolies d'être toujours
à la télévision c'est joli de dire je
fais ceci mais finalement rien ne se
fait merci et bien de sesto d'avoir
répondu à nos questions dans ce sens
qu'a dit spécial municipal réalisé par
cédric berkeley merci